most of the guys that are have been in
shape for like almost all their lives
have simplified most things to just like
calories and protein and lift heavy
occasionally right which is more or less
what we've tried to do you can be more
convenient same with money right I was
funny because we had this idea that came
out when we were talking to Stan I was
like I don't really trained that much
anymore he's like me neither he's like
he's like our trainer like once a week
maybe you know and he's like it's crazy
how little I have to do to like look the
way I do he said something like yeah
dude just enjoy the fruits of your labor
and for some reason there was like a
spark that went off and I was like oh I
have a passive body right it's like
active income and passive income but
stored away enough active effort that
now you can maintain you know this
physique with like pretty passive effort
like I can still eat Twizzlers every day